that so we have wrote of uh Sherman had
given the next talk it's good so what
I'm going to tell you about is joint
work with Jeanette Garland her student
blog a bunch and I have two goals with
this talk one is not to overburden your
digestive system right now so let's talk
will be a very technical and the other
is to give you a small taste of
something from distributed computing
that I think you might find you know
cute and interesting so let me start
with distributed proofs in general
before we add in interaction so in the
in the setup here we have a network of
very weak computational devices and they
are connected over some graph topology
which we typically don't know in advance
so every one of these toasters only has
a very local view network and they want
to do something but this might be too
hard for them to do by themselves so
they want to interact with some very
powerful prover that will help them do
whatever it is that they want to do so
they're going to ask the prover this is
the classical motivation for interactive
proofs and delegation and so on another
motivation here is that distributed
algorithms are notoriously buggy and
really hard to get right and one thing
that you can do here is sort of think of
this as a certificate of correctness
after I've run my algorithm I want to
think of this proof as a witness that I
did the computation correctly I want it
to be very easy to verify and maybe I
don't care how hard it is to compute
because I had some heavyweight algorithm
already running and doing that
computation form so this is distributed
verification the formalism was
introduced about a decade ago and this
is called proof labeling schemes don't
ask me why
but it's basically distributed NP except
there is no computational aspect it's
all about communique
so what happens here we start out with
this network and like I said every node
initially knows only itself and its
neighbors and it might also have some
inputs that is like an input to the
problem that they want to solve but the
input is private every node has a
separate input and how does a proof
labeling scheme work we have approver
the prover sees everything all the graph
all the inputs everything that there is
to know it assigns to every node and
advise string for a label and then every
node looks at its own label it can see
the labels of its neighbors basically
every node sends its own label to its
neighbors and then it has to decide if
it's happy or not happy okay
it also takes into account its input if
there is an input and we say that this
input and graph are accepted if all the
nodes were happy if some node was
unhappy then it's considered rejected so
this is a proof labeling scheme and the
important parameter here is how long is
the proof how many bits of advice does
the prover have to give to each
individual no and you might think that
the communication pattern here is
extremely restricted why do I assume
that what they do is take their into my
string and send it to their neighbors
the answer is it doesn't really matter
if there was something more complicated
that they wanted to do the prover could
just tell them here is what you would
have said after I gave you this
particular proof string right and now
this is the new proof and as usual with
non-deterministic communication
complexity this assumption is without
loss of generality as long as everything
is deterministic so as long as they
don't have extra randomness after
which they don't in the classical setup
okay so these are proof labeling schemes
just to get an impression of the lay of
the land here is a trivial proof
labeling scheme that works for anything
that you want to do assume that there's
no input there's only the graph I want
to check some graph property what I can
do is ask the prover to tell every node
the full graph okay so the honest prove
er gives every node the graph this is
its advice string and now we have to
verify because the prover might not be
honest so what we do is two things first
of all we make sure that we all go out
to the same graph okay so we exchange
our advice strings and we check that
they're the same and second you check
that in the graph that the prover told
you you really do have the neighbors
that you have in reality okay so if the
prover lied and told us some graph
that's incorrect some node will reject
and this is enough for us so that's the
preview proof labeling scheme it only
takes n squared bits so our only play
here is between N squared and one okay
there is also something interesting that
you can do with one bits of advice
yeah so for example you can verify
bipartite nests you can ask the prover
to just tell you you know here is the
side that you belong to and then this is
easy to verify that it's really exactly
yes so there's many things that you can
do with even a constant size advice and
logarithmic size advices even better
here's an interesting thing that you can
do with log sized advice you can verify
that the graph is connected as long as
you know its size because if you don't
know what size it's basically it's
hopeless so what do you do I you ask the
prover to tell the nodes of rooted
spanning tree so what does it tell every
particular node here is your parent in
the tree
here's your distance from the root of
the tree and here's the size of your
subtree and how do we verify this you
make sure that if you're not the root
then your parent has distance one less
than you you make sure that the size of
the your subtree is one plus the sum of
your children's sub trees and you make
sure that if you are the roots then the
size of your sub tree is in and that's
it this only takes log n bits for each
one of these things and this is from the
original paper that was saying okay so
oh you put your finger on something
really interesting so in very recent
work we tried to sort of this Oh in the
original paper there was a log in lower
bound but you can ask where is it coming
from there's a few different things here
does it come from the distance does it
come from the size okay or maybe it
comes from having to tell you who your
parent is which is also logging this
turns out that the right answer is it's
log log n plus the diameter of the graph
okay so really it's coming from the
distance it's good enough to have a
constant approximation of the size you
can work it out you don't even need to
know your parents you can work that out
as well
but you really do need the distance so
the graph has small diameter then you
can get a slightly better spanning tree
verification ski
this is not even published it's just a
small observation okay so let's uh let's
add some interaction to the mix so we
defined something that is basically like
distributed a.m. or distributed MA or
you know any pattern of interaction that
you would like and a protocol in
distributed ma works like this are nodes
each one sends a random challenge just a
random string to the proving it's a
separate and private random string for
each one of the nodes okay so they have
sort of you know randomness with the
prover but not with each other and then
the prover sends back an answer to each
one of the notes and now they have to
decide if they're happy or unhappy and
to do this again so they have their own
advice their neighbors advice as well
and the randomness that they sent to the
prover based on this they decide and if
there is input to the problem then they
also take into account
okay they do not get the neighbors
randomness if they want the neighbors
randomness then we can ask the prover to
tell them that but they pay for it okay
so that's a good point
just because in this context it doesn't
make sense where would they have this
randomness from where how would they
know it but another point is also they
don't have extra randomness after the
prover gives them the the advice that
would be a a okay so just like this you
can continue to define it with more
rounds of interaction you can go to
Merlin Arthur Merlin Arthur Merlin
Arthur Brewers yeah we're gonna see one
protocol for each one of these okay
that's the the basic definition and we
want it to ask okay this interaction
health can you do more things with
interaction than you could do without
interaction can we prove lower bounds
for the so to party a.m. lower bounds
are notoriously elusive and non existent
but can we prove something here this is
much much weaker than general a.m. and
the answer is that we came up with our
yes of course interaction helps
maybe but we don't know if you can prove
lower bounce you know we have a lower
bound that's extremely simple and kind
of weak but I'm cautiously optimistic
about this so the focus of this work was
more on the upper bound so what did we
show we took a problem that is known to
be extremely hard for the non
interactive setting the graph symmetry
problem Oh Jerusalem a second it's known
to be maximally hard this is a paper of
Micah goose back in his former life when
it was in my community and you quest for
mana and we showed that with ma a.m.
Merlin Arthur Merlin you can get the bit
complexity down to log and bits per node
and if you want to squeeze it down to a
M then you can do it in n log N and we
also showed a lower bound for a M log n
bits very easy which I'll show you it's
not clear what what is the answer you're
free I personally believe that it should
be this oh and we also tackled the
poster child for interactive proofs
graph Norma is a morphism and we gave a
protocol which is Arthur Merlin Arthur
Merlin it uses this as a component and
it takes n log n it's graph non
isomorphism is no easier than this
problem so it's also N squared bits
without interaction
okay today I'll probably only have time
to talk about these I also prepared
slides for these because I'm crazy
okay so graph symmetry is asking does
the network graph have some non-trivial
automorphism and here's the lower bound
for the non interactive setting this is
like I said from a paper by Mika and
Yuka Sola you look at a dumbbell graph
like this where the two parts of the
graph are first of all asymmetric each
one of them does not have a non-trivial
automorphism and second I want them to
be sort of canonical representatives I
don't want there to be two possibilities
here that are isomorphic to each other
so from each class of graphs that are
isomorphic to each other I'm just gonna
pick one representative and those will
be my options for h1 and h2 and there's
still roughly 2 to the N squared options
so that's fine and the point is that
this graph oops
what is that this graph has a non
trivial at a morphism
if and only if these two graphs are the
same because you must map this graph
onto this graph in order to get two
knots or more and we ruled out any two
graphs that are isomorphic unless
they're in the same
so basically it's a reduction from
two-party equality it's not phrased that
way in the original paper they basically
prove their non-deterministic roll
around but this is essentially what's
going on ok so here is a Merlin Arthur
Merlin protocol for a graph symmetry
it's very obvious what we want to do we
want the prover to tell us a permutation
to tell us a non-trivial automorphism in
the way that it's going to specify it is
by telling every node here is where I
map you okay no no we should verify that
this really is a non-trivial
automorphism verifying that it's
non-trivial is easy verifying that it's
actually an otter morphism is not so
easy because let's say that this is my
network and the proclaimed yeti you guys
you are mapped over here these guys
don't even get to talk to these guys
they're not neighbors with them ok and
even if they were neighbors with them
everybody has to check that they are
mapped correctly that the edges are
respected by the claims automorphism so
that's gonna take a lot of communication
so it's it's not obvious or at least it
wasn't obvious to us how to actually
verify that the permutation that
approver gave us first of all even is a
permutation and second isn't Auto
morphism the solution that we came up
with is a global solution which is to
hash down the adjacency matrix of the
graph and also the adjacency matrix that
you get after applying the mapping that
the prover gave and to make sure that
they hatch down to the same value if
they do then we believe that it's the
same matrix so it was really an autumn
office
so that's the high-level idea how are we
gonna do this when nobody knows the
adjacency matrix of the graph so we have
to do something local we have to build
this up out of things that an individual
node knows how to do so what does an
individual node know this is what it
knows it can build a matrix like its own
part of the adjacency matrix where the
row corresponding to it is its own
neighborhood in the graph it's the
characteristic vector of its
neighborhood in the got this all use
this notation for the matrix that is
zero everywhere except Rho V and in Rho
V I put the neighborhood and the
adjacency matrix of the graph is just
the sum of all of these sort of local
neighborhood matrices and now you can
probably tell how ready for what I'm
going to do so first some easy
observations if I have a set s let me
denote by you know if I apply a row to s
I'm just looking at all the images if
you look at a permutation row it's an
autumn morphism if and only if for every
vertex if you look at where row maps its
neighborhood and you look at the
neighborhood of where it mapped the
vertex itself this is a better be the
same right that's almost by definition
and from this we see that if we look at
the adjacency matrix and we look at the
per muted adjacency matrix which is yes
Rho is a knots and morphism if and only
if these matrices are the same and this
is good because this particular thing
node V knows it this thing for a
specific node V it also knows it because
it knows where it was mapped its
neighbors can tell it where they were
mapped so every node can compute its own
part of this permutate adjacency matrix
so now we have these local building
blocks and if you take the sum of the
building blocks you get the full matrix
so what we're gonna do we're gonna hash
down this and this using a linear hash
and you know somehow compute the sum and
check and how do we compute the son well
we're gonna do it using a spanning tree
which fortunately we already know how to
do okay so this is conceptually what we
would like to do the prover is gonna
tell a suspending tree it chooses some
spanning tree the leaves of the spanning
tree we'd like them to hash down their
own local view just there the matrix
consisting of you know only their own
neighborhood and then we add up these
hashes to get the hash of the subtree of
each inner note how do you get this you
take your own row and you add the sum
for your children and because it's a
linear function you get to really the
hash of the sum of everything in your
sub tree
ah no I'm gonna show the protocol in a
second but we cannot afford that we
better choose that otherwise that the
prover would just pick some hash that
collides at the right matrices finally
the the root has really the dash of the
Foley Jason C matrix okay and of course
we cannot compute there is no actual
computation there is only verification
so this translates to a check that we
have to make I'm gonna ask the prover
please tell me this sum and I will make
sure that this is sensible so that's the
protocol in full we ask the prover for
what it claims is a non-trivial
automorphism and routed spanning tree
and to make sure that the the thing it
gave us is non-trivial it's easy to just
ask it well root the spanning tree at
some node that is not mapped to itself
so that's what we'll ask for and now we
challenge with some linear hash function
we can afford for it to be really small
it doesn't need to be a really good hash
function it just needs to be linear and
you know fairly and then the prover
tells all the nodes well here's the hash
function that the root shows for all of
you and here are these partial sums that
you would have computed up the tree and
then you just check it check that the
sum for yourself
matches your children's sums and your
own row the root checks that the final
hash value is the same and the checks
that it was not mapped onto itself and
that's it
so everything that's going on here is
only login bits including you know login
bits that I send to the prover okay so
even if I wanted to charge for
randomness that I sent to the prover
that's fine so this is M a.m. it's
really important here that first of all
the prover commits to a permutation it
tells us the permutation and then we
choose the hash function otherwise the
prover would pick a bad hash function
this is actually fairly easy if you're
used to this kind of thinking the root
scent the seed for the hash function -
the prover I require the prover to send
the same seed to everybody and they
check that it's the same but but you can
check for it
okay the prover gives everybody what it
claims is the seed and everybody sends
each other the seed and they check if
they got the same seed and the root
checks that yeah this is really what I
sent to the pool
yeah but this is another reason why the
seed has to be small yeah because we're
going to send it to each other
okay so this is an M a.m. protocol and
how do we get rid of the extra round it
basically means that we have to at the
same time give the permutation and also
the hash function so the prover has a
lot more power and it does but you can
just take a much much bigger hash and
that gets around that problem so if you
pick a hash function that is you know
this big much much bigger then you can
get it to be so big that by a Union
bound when you pick a random hash the
probability that there exists any
mapping and any spanning tree that would
fool the nodes and make them accept is
small may because the number of
permutations and spanning trees is
roughly the size so that's just easy fix
and once we've done this then we can
reverse the order first we send the hash
and then the prover gives us the
presentation and the spanning tree then
we verify in my personal belief is that
this is optimal
Oh questions about the
let me show you the easiest a of lower
bound that you would have ever seen in
your life so we're going to go back to
the set up from the the
non-deterministic lower bound that was
not with interaction so this is what it
looked like we had this dumbbell graph
we're basically asking is H 1 equal to H
2 and this is equality this is basically
still equality so now we're sort of
asking what is the a.m. complexity of
this multi-party version of the quality
with private randomness not really clear
let's just do it by reduction from two
parties so I'm going to have Allison Bob
simulate so Alice simulates all of the
notes here Bob simulates all of the
notes here okay so in particular they
have to sort of send a lot of randomness
to the river because even if every note
here only sends small number of random
bits to the prover together it builds up
to a lot and and now it's basically
two-party equality but it's in the
following weird model where Alex and Bob
have no shared randomness with each
other but they have let's just assume
unbounded shared randomness each one of
them separately okay so this is a weird
kind of model but it's that's what we
end up with it's not hard to see that
equality in this model still requires
log in bits of communication and this is
the proof if you give me a protocol for
this model that has C bits we can easily
convert it to a private coin protocol
with no prove ER it has to to the C it's
how do we do it Alice picks random
string and she tells Bob the list of all
proofs that would convince her to accept
when this is her input and this is her
reminisce
and Bob does the same thing he tells
Alice this is the list of proofs that
would make me accept on my input in
randomness and we accept if there is a
proof that both of them are ok so from
am with cbits we went to private coin
with two to the cbits seems like there's
a problem here right because the quality
with private coins is log in base so I
promised log and I'm only delivering log
log in the trick is to notice that this
is actually a simultaneous for a call
base Alice and Bob can just announce
their lists to the referee the referee
checks for an intersection and that's it
and the private coin communication
complexity of equality is Lewton so from
this we get the lower bound of log
oh so that is pretty much it let me say
maybe a few words about graphing on
isomorphism so graphing on isomorphism
you have two graphs any one except if
and only if they're not is amorphic not
even clear what this problem should mean
in our model because we only have one
graph the communication network so
there's a few different ways you can
extend it but they all pretty much end
up being the same here's one of them you
basically say well G 0 is the
communication graph and G 1 is just your
input every node is given a set of
neighbors and that's their G 1 neighbors
and that's okay but it doesn't matter
you can allow them to communicate over
some arbitrary third graph as well it
doesn't really matter the classical
protocol that we all know and love for
graphing on isomorphism it's the Pepsi
versus Colleges we want to check if the
two graphs are really the same or not we
pick a random one and a permutation we
send the per muted graph that we chose
and if the graphs are isomorphic then
the prover has no way to tell which of
the graphs we chose so we asked it to
tell us the graphs are not isomorphic it
can always tell us but if the graphs are
isomorphic
it can only guess that's the classical
protocol if you try to instantiate this
protocol in our setting there's pretty
much no way to do it because we're
asking for a lot of things that you
cannot do how do I even compute this
thing how do i globally choose one of
the two graphs without going through the
prover the nodes cannot talk to each
other so that's pretty much impossible
so you have to go back to complexity 101
what you had enough to learn from module
and recall the public coin protocol for
graph not isomorphism
what happens in this protocol is they
observe that if we look at the set of
graphs that are isomorphic to one of our
two graphs
if the two graphs are isomorphic to each
other this is the same set the graphs
that are isomorphic to g1 it's the same
set of the graphs that are isomorphic to
g2 so there should be an factorial of
them number of permutations and of
course I'm lying but if the graphs are
non isomorphic then these sets are
disjoint so there should be twice as
many graphs are isomorphic to either the
first one or the second one okay why am
i lying because if the graph has some
symmetries then these symmetries will
map to the same graph so you don't
really get what do you really get
something that's you have to sort of
compensate for the number of
automorphisms and the way that this is
compensated for is to just add in you
know ok so what do they do in Goldwasser
sleep so they define this set which is
basically the union of the two sets we
have before a set of all graphs that are
is amorphic so either the first graph or
the second one plus give me an autumn
morphism of the graph that you choose
and this really is of size n factorial
if the graph sorry
it's morphic or 2n factorial if they're
not and this is now what we would like
to test is this a really large set or a
much smaller set and what they do in the
protocol is they pick a hash function
they give the prover a challenge in the
form of an image just a random image
from the range of the hash function and
they ask it to invert they ask it please
give me some element from the set there
are maps to this image that I gave you
if the set is very big the Foubert can
probably do it the set is very small the
prover probably cannot do it and that's
the idea of the protocol here
and this is the protocol that we were
able to implement in our model let me
just say one word about why it's
non-trivial the goal versus if so
protocol needs a hash function that is
pairwise independent because we need the
hash function not to distort too much
the size of the set that we have we're
trying to estimate the size of the set
you cannot get pairwise independent hash
functions let's have a really small
scene this is an exercise okay so there
is no hash function that does what we
want so we had to sell for less we had
to first of all relax the pairwise
independence to almost fairways
independence and we still weren't able
to get it linear
okay so we had to drop linearity as well
and just find something else we
basically constructed a simple will
almost fair wise independent hash
function that you can compute up a tree
but not by summing it's not linear you
do something interactive proofs I think
that they are an interesting way to push
what we understand about am on one side
distributed computing on the other side
lower bounds may or may not be more
approachable than they are for the two
party case but there is a lot more to
work with than there is when you try to
prove a two-party lower bounds so for
example one really interesting question
in my opinion is how hard is it in a.m.
to verify that approver that my input
sorry is a valid spanning tree why do I
think that this is maybe approachable
because like we said spanning trees are
about distance I have to show you that
there is a path from you to the root so
in particular I have to somehow connect
nodes that are very far apart they don't
talk to each other they only communicate
through the prover and all of the nodes
have to go through the proof okay so
somehow there's a lot of information
that needs to be conveyed here the
prover is the only communication sort of
coordination
mechanisms so maybe we can exploit that
to prove the bounds and another question
that I think is interesting this is
maybe towards the symmetry problem or
graph Amana has morphism how hard is it
to verify that a given input is a
permutation so let's say I think my
nodes are on the line like this everyone
is given a number and I want them to
check if these numbers are a permutation
of 1 to N or not ok this seems like the
heart of you know why we couldn't get
our protocol to work for a m and it will
be interesting to see if this is all
right so I'll conclude here no no this
was all very specific so in general one
thing that we didn't do is the basics
like develop this kind of underlying
hierarchy theory or anything like that
this still needs to be done I mean it's
an open problem still for communication
complexity right whether the hierarchy
is strict or not but there are still
some kind of low-hanging fruit here that
we just have not yet
right so for example it's known for two
parties that ma is no stronger than am
yeah what are the problems I did see a
major all of the inputs yes yeah you
think things might change if you
actually if you add the yes it could be
easier to prove lower bounds for example
you can look at generalized inner
product on a network you know with large
inputs why you know very low discrepancy
it might help
these are just the problems that have
been interesting for the field before so
we wanted to look at them and see what
we could do but there is no particular
reason why we restrict attention to them
[Applause]